speaking of the Fred's we just saw him
take Isaac Walther at 179 here overall
in round number 6 so Walter heading in
PK Subban heading out and on his way out
he had this message to the Preds fans
earlier today alright to everyone in
Nashville city of Nashville state of
Tennessee everybody at the Nashville
organization everyone in the front
office from ownership barb and herb
Fritch down to GM David Pyle coaching
staff led by Peter Laviolette and
everyone in the front office I just want
to thank you guys for your continued
professionalism over the past three
years and believing me and giving me an
opportunity I believe we got close to
our goal didn't achieve what we wanted
while I was there and that hurts but to
all those Nashville fans out there I
just want to let you guys know in that
locker room you guys have an amazing
group of players now moving forward you
guys know the deal I'm a devil let's go
it's on to all those New Jersey Devil
fans out there let's go I mean I don't
know I'm with Red Bull this is the
closest I don't got any merch yet you
know what to the all the fans that go to
the rock every night the rock Prudential
Center to support the New Jersey Devils
can you smell what The Rock is cookin I
don't really know this is the only thing
I got I mean it's the Rock's logo but do
you smell what The Rock is cooking I
don't know I got no merch I got no
memorabilia I got nothing with dirt
Jersey Devils on it but I just want to
tell you guys are you guys ready for the
supinator cuz I'm ready to go let's go
Lucy we're going to Jersey